hi guys my name is Jess McDonald I'm
sorry T and welcome back to how sparse
we are continuing on with the retro game
theme for video game History Month and
today we're playing which is like oh
yeah keeping the peace Kingdom just
killing me
use your BP here time equip yourself
what's a BP it's what it is beautiful
gaming memory this isn't it good police
offices running
look how pretty she is oh my God look at
handy's wow she looks much more much
more high-res here japanese go ahead on
I bet they had it like anybody else
forget Lara Croft actually that was very
hilarious that's too high that's a knee
high how is she supposed to get up that
she's refusing to go be insane serene
that makes no sense these jeans oh my
god once how I know they did for real a
plus everything's gonna be okay outright
lie guess the models look have a bite to
eat mom here it's wrinkle-free day i
guess every day is free coffee day now
oh if it's a lock throw a chair through
the window come on woman it's just glass
is so much good furniture for chucking
jolly Joker tonight making jokes at a
time like this as good as my coffee jerk
it looks hot now I'm just chilling yeah
okay it's just need to catch my breath
they're all dead yeah dude don't ask
where's friends I you know they're all
dead that's so offensive every one of
these games is so insensitive
Here Come blue she's like where all the
other offices are you crazy
where's
all those bodies I saw were they your
friends oh they were I'll be where your
friends oh sure why is she breathing you
okay oh oh oh my god
see oldest trick in the book huh oh gee
where's looks like it's gonna bang dude
don't look at the face don't like no
creature do this what guy line oh it's
creepy but she's breaking she's breaking
ah she's breaking oh oh
the spine came out of back your face is
still nice there
oh wow that just made that happen to him
sit down
well that's terrifying oh I should have
put them back on no it'd have been the
best yes having a tantrum now metal
implant don't take it that's disgusting
just pried it from its corpse and then
it gets up again sorry
oh no he didn't even wait for us to get
down that's like way past double tap
it's quadruple tap Wow look at me like
oh my god oh my god oh oh you left the
battle lose points for losing Wow this
is not like other survival horror games
no mansion did wait for it you have fate
you idiot I thought this was an
emergency
you're gonna read jinx
they should've knocked each other out
oh wow that looks like I can even find
okay I'm starting to worry about this
boy after the three dozens buddy you're
starting to worry we should run what we
should run just like we should run we
should run like we should punch
Oh bad fishes bad fishies he's doing
Taichi
oh my god oh my god
you go like cat feet oh I'm second feet
my god these are the dumbest white
things I've ever seen
failing to see the survival heart
actually killing things is fun that is
true
where's our friend Barry Sebastian I
beat you the legs how dare you buy me a
so much [ __ ] wildlife
I added that together
Wow this is this is Wesson shooting fish
in a barrel this is shooting fish out of
water on a con grab a B you would put up
a fight
Oh oh my god well
yes I like that why is she so my god
no [ __ ] die oh yes you are side Yves
- thank you so everyone who requested
that game and I hope you enjoyed that
playthrough yeah
we'll be back next week at the same time
continuing on the retro game theme for
video game History Month
this was house of horrors I'm sorry I'm
Jeff thank you for watching everyone
thanks guys bye